hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 10 recap and
review the episode was titled gone and
it was written and directed by series
creator Sam s mail this video will
contain spoilers if you haven't watched
episode 10 yet so go do that first and
come back and watch this video after you
finish this was a weird episode for me I
didn't love it and I didn't hate it a
lot of important stuff happened and we
got some good character moments but it
just didn't have the impact of like if
you explained to me what was going to
happen or what happened and I thought
about it as compared to watching it if
that makes sense it's fine I say that as
a really big fan of the series and
generally a big fan of the character
episodes this one just for me personally
wasn't my favorite I'm guessing that
feelings were probably mixed on it some
people probably really loved it other
people might not have wanted to sit
through it at this point in the story
but let's go through the whole thing
talk about what happened and then I'll
talk a little bit more about what I
thought at the end things start out at
the hospital Dom is alive she's been
through surgery she's recovering in the
hospital talking to someone from the FBI
on the news she learns about the Deus
group hack we get a report about the
documents that were leaked they haven't
all been verified but they are causing
problems for the people who are
mentioned in them and we see right away
that white rose has been identified we
see Minister dongs face on the screen
and it says that the Chinese Minister is
in fact the hacker known as white road
Tom puts two and two together realizes
she had a chance to stop white rose back
in China didn't figure out what was
going on in that situation and we
learned that she has been put on
administrative leave the FBI has her
family in a safe house but she can't
visit she's essentially stuck there and
as far as we can tell she is a sitting
duck in the hospital she killed Janice
who was her dark army handler so we have
to imagine that the dark army would want
to visit and have some words with her
about that situation she also loses her
value to them if she's on administrative
leave and she can't really do anything
in the FBI either except for be
investigated by them which none of that
is very
good either way we don't find out what
happens with that because she decides
she doesn't want to be in the hospital
and she has them discharge her against
medical advice this set up one of my
favorite shots from the episode where we
see her sitting outside and after the
orderly left her they're not letting her
get out of the wheelchair it keeps
setting off the automatic door which
sort of opens and closes behind her she
makes it back to her apartment and
decides to put together a grilled cheese
sandwich she uses Mayo instead of butter
on the bread and that kind of made me
laugh because I remember different
people doing that when I was a kid
Darlene shows up as she's eating her
sandwich and once her to get out of
there
Dom isn't with the idea of leaving and
it seems like her motivation is that she
wants to see her family and she wants to
apologize for what she's put them
through we can see her wanting to do
that based on what we've seen from her
and her family throughout this season
but Darlene makes a pretty good point to
that what it really looks like is she's
just sitting there waiting to die and
that she needs to go not able to
convince her Darlene eventually smashes
her Alexa on the ground
Tom eventually agrees it sets things up
for the road trip and they head out
together where they run into Elliot at a
motel this is the only little bit of
Elliot that we get in the episode we see
him sitting out a laptop with the thumb
drive from Phillip price he's looking at
documents on that outside the motel we
see him holding a little device in his
hand I believe this is something like
the rubber ducky but I'm not sure
exactly what this thing is it seems to
be key in his plans for what he's gonna
do when he goes to Washington Township
plant that part seems clear Darlene
tries to get him to leave
he says he's not done he says he's gonna
have to go to Washington Township and
the darlene can't come and she says that
she doesn't want to like she's basically
done it's a sad moment and it kind of
felt like damn Darlene's gonna die which
is something I didn't want to have
happen but we'll get to all of that
later as they're talking Dom makes her
way into the room only to find Leon
sitting on the bed which is frightening
for her because the last time that she
saw him was at the barn at the end of
season 3 Leon doesn't remember though
he's rolling a joint watching TV and he
says have we met before she reminds him
of the bond
and it all starts to make sense to him
and we go back to that idea that now
Leon has moved on from the dark army and
he's just a hired gun
after Darlene returns the three of them
go on the road they're on the way to
Boston they're taking the scenic route
and Leon says that they're trying to
avoid all of the dark army and there are
lwas which are rich white [ __ ] he
says that they are the dark Army's
favorite clients they are lwas they stop
at a rest stop so he can go to the
bathroom which he says he needs to steal
a mirror which is a Kurt Vonnegut
reference that no one knows which leads
him to share his distaste for the fact
that nobody reads anymore
earlier Darlene had mentioned that
everything was ready to Eliot about
redistributing the money that they stole
from the day's group she thought he
should do the honors he said no this was
hers so she ends up doing that at the
rest stop with DOM it's a pretty good
moment probably my favorite part of this
episode I guess we see Tom being Dom
wondering about the specifics and if
laws were broken if crimes were
committed we see Darlene told her to
relax she gives her a kiss and we
watched the faces of everyone as they
start to get their alerts that they're
equine transfers went through that they
weren't expecting Tom looks down and she
said that everyone get this much so we
don't know exactly how much but Darlene
says it's the biggest redistribution of
wealth in the history of mankind
explains how these people wrote the laws
to benefit themselves so it didn't
matter that they were breaking the laws
and that her and Eliot basically Robin
Hood did all of them and it's pretty
cool it's enjoyable I don't know how
realistic it is but I think it's fine as
far as I'm concerned it's a TV show
I'm fine with believing that this
benefited everyone a little bit at least
in their normal lives and struck a blow
to the people who are at the top there
and what I think stands out the most
about this is that Tom moves past her
cynicism her suspicion and they kind of
just have that moment they're together
it's nice that they get that moment
considering they were just prisoners of
the dark army not all that long ago and
everything else that's happened to them
throughout this story after that they go
to the airport and we get a cameo from
Irving I wouldn't say it's a return he
just sort of pops up at the airport on
the first watch this really
me off because I couldn't decide if
there was something more going on with
this or not was it a setup with
something gonna happen it felt awkward
seeing your returner Irving is
definitely something that I wanted to
see it just felt a little bit forced I
mean it was cool to see his book it was
cool to see that he's still out there in
the world the interaction was funny just
like everything he's in but in the
background it just sort of felt like why
would she believe anything that he says
and yeah she was scared but when she
leaves it's just sort of like she leaves
the whole thing behind I don't know it
was weird to me I don't know what other
people thought about it good to see
everything back but not my favorite
Irving scene Tom and Darlene talk about
it they seem to accept that the dark
Army's not interested in them anymore
and Dom hints that she doesn't really
want to go to Budapest she wants to get
back to see her family
Darlene's pushing for her to still come
even though it wasn't her idea with
Cisco's idea to go to Budapest the dark
armies not after them so they're not
running away but still she wants her to
come and we know Darlene has feelings
for Dom but it kind of comes out in this
that that's not the motivating factor
anyways what's really going on is
Darlene can't really stand to be by
herself she says this in a couple
different ways as they're talking and
you get the idea that she's just
frightened of being alone Dom on the
other hand is like the opposite she
doesn't want to leave because she has
all this stuff in place even though that
life that she's been leading has kept
her like where she can't sleep for years
according to what she says so she
doesn't want to try something new she
doesn't want to let go and it all comes
down to this rom-com kind of situation
was definitely not a term I was
expecting to use in relation to mr.
robot and an episode recap they
eventually start to say goodbye Dom
gives her a number someone working in
cybersecurity says they need you Darlene
says they can't handle me they go back
and forth it's pretty sad and it feels
like a goodbye the goodbye with Elliot
and the fact that herbing is there and
the fact that there's been theories that
Darlene's gonna die in a plane crash the
whole time or in the back of my mind
anyways and it started to feel like
maybe that was going to happen Darlene
was gonna leave and then something
terrible was gonna happen and then Dom
was gonna be left to have to deal with
that although at the same time and this
is probably where the episode was really
not working for me we had mr. robot tell
Magda
and young Elliot in the boardroom that
Darlene might be the key so we just had
that introduced recently DOM is not the
important one here Darlene is definitely
the key character after you had to pick
one of the two so Dom being left behind
to deal with the tragedy of Darlene
being killed on a flight that they were
on together that doesn't really work
like where do they fit that into the
last three hours so as I was watching it
I was just sort of like well this
doesn't really feel right it doesn't
feel right and then it turned into this
thing where Tom starts to leave
Darlene starts to freak out she starts
to have a panic attack they got this pop
song in the background Tom gets to the
exit can't go through it
Darlene gets to the ticket gate can't
scan or ticket goes into the bathroom
and goes into full-blown panic attack
Tom boards the plane just missing
Darlene as she ran into the bathroom
Darlene works her way through the panic
attack in it this is a pretty good
moment here where the woman's asking her
behind her if she needs help and she
says no I can take care of myself and
that really is the big moment where she
comes to that understanding and I also
really like the fact that when dawn lets
go she decides not to get up she just
sits back she's able to sleep on the
plane
everyone was telling her that she needed
to get some sleep and she finally does
in the end it all works out I feel like
this could be the last time we see Dom I
feel like it will work as an ending for
her character as far as what's going on
in the rest of the story Darlene I think
has a part to play so I definitely don't
think that's the last we're gonna see of
her but it could be and with three
episodes left that's where we're at we
did find out that the finale will be a
two-parter it's gonna air on the same
night so we have two more installments
with mr. robot to come it feels like the
dark Army has been somewhat neutralized
at least from the news reports we know
he left White Rose at her apartment with
the FBI knocking on the door we heard
the gunshots there's gonna be the
aftermath of that but more importantly
Elliot's on his way to Washington
Township and we have to imagine that
those two are going to have their face
off which we know has been coming at
that point it could work out that Elliot
will go to Washington Township and do
something and then they'll get together
after it's hard to say at this point as
far as the documents and screens that we
saw with Eliot looking at the stuff from
White Rose oh it really shows as far as
I can tell
is that white rose does have a particle
accelerator like the LHC we pretty much
saw that in season three I don't know
that anything on the screens give away
anything as far as what White Rose is
planning to do with that it just seems
to indicate that moving the project of
the Congo will improve the capacity
they'll be able to get better results
from the experiments that they're doing
I like the Leon parts I thought Leon did
a pretty good job here of being the
third wheel with Tom and Darlene
Vonnegut references were fun for me I
was a big Vonnegut fan growing up and
it's been a long time since I read any
of his books but it's funny to think
about Kilgore Trout and some of the
crazy ideas that are related to him the
thing about Mears is referring to
something that he thought he called
Mears leeks and like to pretend that
they were holes between multiple
universes if I recall correctly so when
Leon saying he's gonna steal a mirror
he's going to take a leak and I'm not
reading too much into the parallel
universes thing personally but I'm
guessing that a lot of people will draw
that connection to whiterose and her
project so it wasn't a personal favorite
of mine this episode but I think it was
a pretty good ending to the whole idea
of Darlene and Dom I have a feeling that
some people probably really liked it and
that is okay too
let me know what you thought in the
comments did you think this was a good
character episode are you happy that
Darlene and Dom both got over their
internal blocks and were able to move on
by the end of the episode what do you
think about her being showing back up do
you think we could take what he said at
face value he's really on a book tour
and the dark army really doesn't care
about Darlene and Dom anymore what's
Elliott planning what did he have and
that little device that he was carrying
what do you think his plan is for
Washington Township and how his White
Rose gonna bounce back from the
situation that she's in and what is she
going to show Eliot to try to show him
that they're on the same side please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching guys I will
talk to you soon